Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P, here is a caller who says
if Trump thinks that by running for president
again, he'll avoid getting indicted. He is
wrong. This is the opinion of the caller.
Speaker 5: Trump is talking about running
for president to avoid being indicted.
There's no that's not going to work.
Merrick Garland is not going to stop any
indictments or investigations just because he
declares that he's running for president. His only
option is to move to another country that does not
extradite. Extradite. And he'd have to
stay there for the rest of his life.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, listen, I generally agree
that Trump running for president is not going to
prevent an indictment. However, it is completely
plausible that if there is an indictment
forthcoming against Donald Trump and Donald Trump
is again the sitting president, it's after January
of 2025. Trump won in November 24, is sworn in
in 25, and then the indictment comes forward.
I do believe that Donald Trump will at least
have a reasonable attempt to make to say, no,
no, no, no, no, I'm the president. I can't
be dealing with this right now. He used it
while president the first time around to avoid
having to testify and respond to requests from
various women who had filed lawsuits against
Donald Trump. So he will absolutely do that.
But to the extent that Trump wants to. From what
we're told, get out of legal trouble in terms of
indictment by announcing his candidacy. I agree
that that's not going to do anything. That's not
going to work. Now, whether there's actually
any charges forthcoming remains to be seen. We
have a fantastic bonus show today. First of all,
Democrats forced every Republican in the House
to take a stance on marriage equality. And I know
that it's July of 2022, but there are many, many,
many House Republicans who voted against marriage
equality. Secondly, Joe Biden has announced
some incremental climate initiatives. We're
going to talk about what they are and we're going
to talk about whether they are more substance
or whether they are more fluff. This includes
promoting offshore wind and some other things. So
we will talk about that and also the meaning and
discussion around declaring a climate emergency.
And thirdly, there's a bipartisan Senate group
that has reached a deal to reform the Electoral
Count Act. This is something we've been looking at
for a while, and this relates to the circumstances
that presented themselves after the 2020 election,
the Mike Pence, etc. craziness. There seems to
be some progress among this Senate group. We'll
tell you what is contained there and whether
it might actually more seriously prevent
what could have happened in 2020 from even
having a shot at happening in the future.
Get access to the bonus show by signing up at
join pacman dot com. You can use the coupon code
Obama now Obama to get a roughly 60% discount
off of the cost of membership. And lastly,
remember, I want you to show up to my viewers town
hall on Tuesday, July 26th. This will be 6 p.m.
Eastern, 3 p.m. Pacific. It'll be if you want to
watch, it'll be streaming live on the Pacman Live
YouTube channel. YouTube.com slash Pacman Live.
You can just watch. You don't have to participate.
If you'd like to chat with me during the
town hall, we will be live at 6 p.m. Eastern,
3 p.m. Pacific and taking questions via
discord. And of course our web site members
at join Pacman dot com will get priority access
with a separate member waiting room in order
to talk to me so all great things and remember
tonight 7 p.m. eastern I will be streaming what
is at least as of now believed to be the final
committee hearing for the January six committee,
expecting excerpts of Donald Trump struggling
to report his record, his go home speech after
the Trump riots. Trump's former lawyer, Pat
Cipollone is expected to testify. Huge tonight
will be live on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook.
And I hope to see you there. I really do.